[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy el
presidente de colombia iván duque
desplegó a la policía y al ejército para
desbloquear las vías que permanecen
cerradas por manifestantes desde hace
tres semanas mientras siguen las
críticas por la represión de las fuerzas
de seguridad a las protestas
antigubernamentales y chile- acudió a
las urnas para elegir a los redactores
de su nueva constitución y los
ciudadanos le dieron un golpe a los
partidos tradicionales eligiendo como
constituyentes a una mayoría de
candidatos independientes que tendrán un
año para redactar la nueva carta magna
y canadá tiene el peor registro por
muertes de kobe 19 de los adultos
mayores en hogares de retiro 30% más
alto que en otras naciones ricas
revisamos por qué
y vamos de inmediato a colombia con
nuestra historia principal a más de 20
días de protestas en contra del
presidente iván duque el diálogo entre
el gobierno y los organizadores del paro
sigue estancado el comité nacional del
paro acusó al gobierno de negarse a
negociar y convocó a una nueva gran
jornada de protestas para este miércoles
los convocantes a la huelga aseguraron
además que las autoridades no reconocen
la gravedad y la dimensión de la
violencia contra los manifestantes que
según la defensoría del pueblo deja más
de 40 personas fallecidas por el uso
excesivo de la fuerza de acuerdo con la
ong temblores más de 1000 personas
fueron detenidas de manera arbitraria y
hubo 16 casos de violencia sexual sobre
este último flagelo hay indignación
especialmente por el caso de una joven
de 17 años que se suicidó después de
haber sido detenida y abusada
sexualmente presuntamente por cuatro
integrantes de la policía que calificó
la denuncia como falsa y ruin la
brutalidad del caso de allison menéndez
convocó a cientos de mujeres a las
calles
la policía no me cuida me cuida a mis
amigas esta es una de las arengas que se
escuchan en las manifestaciones de
colombia para pedir justicia por las al
menos 16 mujeres que han sido víctimas
de violencia sexual en 15 días de
protestas según la ong temblores también
estamos de luto por todo lo que ha
pasado en el marco del paro nacional en
colombia han habido
[Aplausos]
exacerbadas de muertes y de agresiones
tensiones y multiplicadas
en este estallido social la mayoría de
hechos de abuso policial contra las
mujeres corroborados por organizaciones
internacionales ha ocurrido cerca de
estaciones de la policía lugares que
deberían brindarles protección a el
gobierno prometió eliminar las manzanas
podridas nuestra fuerza pública
actúa
con obediencia absoluta a la
constitución y la ley
todas las órdenes operativas que se
imparten siempre se enmarcan en la
garantía de los derechos humanos y si se
presentan violaciones por conductas
individuales de miembro de la fuerza
pública esta sede judicial ethan y se
investigan
según la ong temblores entre 2017 y 2019
se registraron 241 casos de violencia
sexual por parte de la fuerza pública y
la procuraduría general la encargada de
investigar y sancionar a los
funcionarios del estado no ha acusado a
ningún policía por uso excesivo de la
fuerza cometido en 2019 y 2020 menos aún
por delitos sexuales la violencia sexual
ha sido utilizada como arma de guerra en
colombia durante años según cifras de la
unidad para las víctimas desde 1985 al
menos 26 mil 534 mujeres se han visto
afectadas en el marco del conflicto
armado las violaciones fueron cometidas
por el ejército paramilitares y
guerrilleros pero aún hay muchos casos
que no salieron a la luz y al margen de
las protestas apenas en los tres
primeros meses de 2001 en colombia se
registraron 158 feminicidios
seguimos en chile los ciudadanos
finalmente decidieron quiénes serán los
constituyentes los que escribirán el
conjunto de normas que los regirán en
adelante reemplazando a la carta magna-
de augusto pinochet la jornada estaba
prevista para abril pero fue aplazada
debido al alza de contagios de kobe 19
una jornada electoral considerada como
la más importante en tres décadas de
democracia y que nació tras el estallido
social de 2019 los candidatos
independientes obtuvieron un amplio
triunfo dándole un mensaje claro a la
derecha que gobierna el país la
convención que será paritaria 77 mujeres
y 78 hombres tendrá un año para redactar
la nueva carta magna
golpea el establishment chileno los
ciudadanos eligieron a los candidatos de
izquierdas e independientes para
redactar su nueva constitución de los
155 miembros 48 pertenecen a las listas
independientes las dos grandes listas de
la oposición de izquierda sumaron 53
esto sumado a las 17 sillas reservadas
para los pueblos indígenas representa
dos tercios de la asamblea constituyente
los restantes se pertenecen a los
partidos tradicionales el presidente
sebastián piñera reconoció el mensaje la
ciudadanía nos ha enviado un claro y
fuerte mensaje al gobierno y también a
todas las fuerzas políticas
tradicionales
no estamos sintonizando adecuadamente
con las demandas y con los anhelos de la
ciudadanía
y estamos siendo interpelados por nuevas
expresiones y por nuevos liderazgos
para tomar decisiones se necesita el
apoyo de dos tercios de la asamblea por
lo que el resultado se traduce en que
los partidos tradicionales no podrán
bloquear ninguna medida para la nueva
constitución que será redactada desde
junio
la ciudad y sola
el paciente participativo
el voto del fin de semana nació tras el
estallido social de octubre de 2019
cuando miles de ciudadanos se tomaron
las calles en rechazo al aumento del
precio del pasaje del transporte público
dado que se trataba de la mayor alza de
tarifas de la historia reciente un
incremento de 30 pesos chilenos que
elevaba la tarifa a 830 pesos poco más
de un dólar en la época
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estudiantes se llamaron a los ciudadanos
a no pagar el pasaje y al margen de las
movilizaciones pacíficas se registraron
actos de vandalismo
una semana después varias estaciones del
metro de santiago fueron destruidas por
lo que el gobierno de sebastián piñera
desplegó a la fuerza de seguridad lo que
derivó en enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes informados y una brutal
represión
el reclamo evolucionó más allá del
precio del pasaje del transporte y se
empezó a atraer la atención sobre la
carta magna heredada de la dictadura de
pinochet que es percibida como un
conjunto de normas que favorecen los
negocios sobre los derechos ciudadanos
los constituyentes se tienen un año para
redactar una nueva constitución cuya
aprobación será sometida a un nuevo voto
ciudadano
y seguimos en puerto rico- para revisar
otras noticias de las américas el
asesinato de que islas rodríguez ortiz
conmociona a la isla el boxeador félix
verdejo sánchez conocido como el
diamante y quien representó a puerto
rico en los juegos olímpicos de 2012 se
entregó a las autoridades después de que
el cuerpo de la joven de 27 años fue
encontrado según la familia de la mujer
fue asesinada luego de avisarle al
boxeador que estaba embarazada de él en
lo corrido del año se han registrado al
menos 21 feminicidios en la isla un
aumento de más del 60% respecto a 2020
cuando se registraron 60 feminicidios y
por lo que se declaró el estado de
emergencia en enero
los candidatos presidenciales peruanos
pedro castillo y keiko fujimori firmaron
un compromiso para defender la
democracia de cara a la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones esta declaración es el
resultado de una de las campañas más
polarizadas en la historia del país
ambos candidatos despiertan la
desconfianza de los ciudadanos que
consideran que sus propuestas son una
amenaza para la democracia y las
libertades
y eeuu apoyo a unas elecciones libres y
justas en venezuela mientras que la
unión europea aseguró que puede ser un
buen momento para la oposición a nicolás
maduró el consejo nacional electoral
leal al chavismo convocó a elecciones
regionales para el 21 de noviembre un
paso de cara a la negociación propuesta
por juan guaidó reconocido por más de 60
países como el presidente legítimo de
venezuela
y el peor legado de la muerte del cobi
19 es su impacto en la población de
adultos mayores 7 de cada 10 muertes por
coronavirus en canadá se registraron en
hogares de acogida de adultos mayores
30% más que en otras naciones ricas las
peores situaciones se vivieron en
ontario y québec revisamos por qué
la madre de nicole está entre los 5.000
adultos mayores que murieron durante la
primera ola de la pandemia pero no murió
de kobe 19 ni sur constantes y 8 días
antes de su muerte
el doctor llamó para decirme que mi
madre estaba completamente deshidratada
las administraciones ordenaron que nadie
ingrese al establecimiento
la madre de nicole que estaba bien hace
unas semanas fue abandonada a su suerte
no había personal suficientemente
preparado
el personal estaba completamente
abrumado feliz estaba viéndola en la
cámara que le configure en su cuarto
podía ver que sufrían frío
nicole quedó indefensa viendo a su madre
morir a través del teléfono es una de
las muchas víctimas que reflejan la
crisis de los servicios de cuidado a
largo plazo de quebec de acuerdo con las
autoridades de la provincia es en esos
hogares donde casi tres cuartas partes
de las víctimas de kobe 19 de la región
murieron durante la primera ola de los
hogares de cuidado no estaban listos
para la crisis al ser crisis muchas
investigaciones llegaron a la misma
conclusión en quebec y otras provincias
incluyendo notario donde la tercera ola
de la pandemia azota la provincia está
confinada la tercera golpe a toronto tan
fuerte que superó a montreal como
epicentro del virus
candance reinick ha trabajado en
servicios de cuidado de ancianos desde
hace 20 años cree que no se aprendió
nada de la primera ola
lo que nuestros miembros están
experimentando es un agotamiento total y
completo y el gobierno no ha hecho nada
para retener y mantener al personal así
que de hecho la crisis ha empeorado
mucho aquí la segunda ola ha cobrado más
vidas que la primera
las organizaciones proveedoras de
servicios de salud con ánimo de lucro
han visto brotes de gran escala en los
lugares de cuidado que manejan la
investigadora tamara de él y cree que el
modelo de negocios de esas compañías
debe ser revisado por las entidades con
ánimo de lucro toman sus fondos no están
añadiendo a su personal en la misma
manera en que lo hacen en el sector
público o en los hogares sin ánimo de
lucro en canadá wire o en canadá no
tendemos a valorar a las personas
mayores como regla general anual o el
ministro de salud de quebec prometió un
plan de acción exhaustivo y el fin de
las instalaciones privadas sin fondos
del gobierno en ontario una
investigación pública independiente
concluyó que no había plan para proteger
a los residentes en cuidados a largo
plazo
y me despido desde parís adonde llegó el
presidente de joe biden para la
reapertura de los museos bueno su
estatua de cera un sonriente mandatario
estadounidense es ahora parte de la
exposición del museo de cera de huelva
que permanecía cerrado debido a la
pandemia del cob y 19 el museo aún tiene
a otros expresidentes de la unión
americana como georges bush y john
f.kennedy el ex presidente de donald
trump ya no hace parte de la muestra
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho y sigan viendo france24